I think Paul Ryan is a wussy with a
capital P I also think that Donald Trump
would have taken this and run with it if
he could have gotten this thing passed I
don't think he really thought that much
of it and I think right now they want
Paul Ryan to hold the bag I as a
conservative as someone who voted for
Republicans when they said repeal I
thought they meant repeal apparently
there was a miscommunication mistake
yeah I can't stand Paul Ryan but I can
stand Donald Trump for being complicit
Paul Ryan for when it's convenient and
then it's not convenient so I'm just
gonna tell you I'm not on the Trump
train among the Paul Ryan train I think
that the swamp is get it has a lot of
fun to cheese right it's so much I buy
the only wasn't have that right on it so
we're talking about this and who else to
answer on this on cable news but Bernie
Sanders who a rare moment of sincerity
admitted that Obamacare has been a
disaster but his proposal is well take a
guess
okay of course Obamacare has serious
problems deductibles are too high
premiums are too high the cost of health
care is going up in a much faster rate
than it should ideally what where we
should be going is to join the rest of
the industrialized world and guarantee
health care to all people as a right and
that's why I'm going to introduce a
medicare-for-all single-payer program
short term this is what we could do
apologies to whoever get more privatized
programming no it is amazing to me he
says that listen the Affordable Care Act
is broken big government has created a
problem here and the solution is an
entirely broken system for Medicare
which we'll get into in a little bit but
it's like it is what Bernie Sanders does
he talks about how student loans are too
high there for there for more free
college how did he pick
that's like they're going
garage here y'all get rattlin hahahaha
there wants to promise a
medicare-for-all so listen he's right
premiums have gone up about twenty
percent in one year from 2016 to 2017
well when I first heard that to it I
thought it was low twenty two percent
over eight states that went up 30
percent but that's one year that's 2016
to 2017 you added up year over year
since the Affordable Care Act has been
passed you have people paying hundreds
of percentage points more yeah than they
were before deductibles on average are
six thousand per individual right now
twelve thousand per family which was
completely unheard of so for the
ironically named Affordable Care in the
solution from Bernie Sanders and I know
people like him because I think he's
sweet he's genuine versus Hillary
Clinton blah blah okay there but his
solution is Medicare Medicare for all
which is entirely broken system I'll
continue to get into that but a liberal
think tank estimated that Bernie Sanders
proposed plan would add 32 trillion in
federal spending over the next next
thing this isn't the Heritage Foundation
this isn't coming from Fox News it's
coming from a leftist think-tank this is
the best case scenario Medicare at this
point by the way is basically already
insolvent if you look at the CBO report
they plan for it to be completely
insolvent well now and so people are
trumpeting you know Obama care saved
Medicare's what they say well really
this actually is a clever accounting
trick because Medicare is still on the
the brink of insolvency as seen by in
the real world the real world practice
of Medicare since the Affordable Care
Act is that fewer doctors than ever in
the history of the United States are
willing take netiquette one in five
doctors flat out will refuse any new
patients who use Medicare at all and
this is this idea of Medicare for all is
based on we need to get get get we need
to go with your industrialized world
with singleplayer hope get right where I
come from a single-payer health care
system take against why we
now I know I get that anecdotal so let's
get this to the statistics first off
keep in mind that none of these other
countries have to fund national defense
effectively from the entire
industrialized free world that's us and
and their tests I hope are the kind of
taxes that you would complain about it
if you're ready to pay fifty two percent
income tax like people have to pay the
marginal tax rates in Quebec you have
riots in the streets so let's keep that
in mind but let's just get some
quantifiable statistics wait times what
my home province of Quebec if you look
at the wait times for people who claim
or people who have waited over five
hours in emergency room keeps that up
there that's thirty five percent of
people who go to an emergency room in
Quebec that's better than the national
average in Canada at nineteen percent
now you look at those numbers United
States is effectively the best on that
list and let me tell you why that's
because the United States has a five
percent amount of people who've waited
for five hours or more now Germany has
that as does the UK the Netherlands but
if you add up all of the other countries
that have five percent of that kind of a
wait time cumulatively
the average of those countries is
one-tenth the population of the United
States and the Netherlands by the way a
third of their entire citizenry are
privately insured anyway geez so we'll
keep that in mind it's not even close a
little own Canada having a tenth of the
population one-tenth the population and
they're met basically wait times have
been the United States and anywhere else
quality of care well listen they use the
best technology they have the best
technology most medical research is
coming out of the United States not only
most medical research coming out of the
United States but they're the ones who
are actually able to use it and actually
make it more affordable to the most
amount of people in their countries just
for an example where I come from in
Canada the United States we have nine
times per capita nine times
I remember being absent I'm RI machines
cry nine times the MRI machines per
person of Canada your rate of dying from
breast cancer prostate cancer picture
cancer can be up to two times the amount
in New Zealand or the UK Germany
depending on which kind of a cancer it
is it basically your best chance of
surviving a terminal illness
is being in the United States and that's
across the board that's across the
entire economic spectrum and Bernie
Sanders likes to act as though there's
there's classism here the United States
and there's equality there's equality
amongst the crappy care in these other
countries right first off you're taking
or weed in countries are taking
countries attend to the population
entirely homogeneous population and the
care sucks but the argument is at least
everyone gets sucky care but that's not
even the case as you see with Canada's
they start to open it to privatize
system what ends up happening when you
have privatized health care along with a
social socialized health care only the
super wealthy get to go to in Canada
what they now call super hospitals or as
we know them in United States hospitals
where they can get the details here
anyone else be get it put in the lines I
have a monitor for an MRI so let's go
with let's go with that Bernie Sanders
it's it's the compassionate thing to do
in like this video subscribe by clicking
the subscribe button it's Atkinson
assist circle now used to be a square
which most buttons aren't squares what
sits on a phone they're square buttons
on phones with most buttons are circles
you understand what I'm talking about or
what's the recommended video which is
popping up in a box or subscribe at
lateral credit.com flashmob join the mud
clip so you can get the daily show and
that means that you are not beholden to
the YouTube censoring overlords so let's
be honest you like being there where you
are under their thumb power bottom you